husband hey children I'm just not ready
I can't wait for you anymore
I don't wanna lose you I don't either
three reasons why I shouldn't buy you a
drink I'm sorry I'm late
you look beautiful walk away walk away I
looked over and look like you needed a
little help same but like dying no man
in your life not anymore
some but like a diamond shouldn't be so
hard you're right it's simple
nice to meet you Oh does he have a
brother beautiful
damn gonna come with me to my parents
for the fourth I have these two
front-row tickets to the Giants game and
I was wondering if you'd go with me
would you mind if I take a picture of
this car maybe ask my boyfriend when he
gets out it was like a switch went off
you know I never hurt you right
do I I think I jump into things
sometimes Oh
how about we start over I can't believe
he's here he's out there he's watching
me that email went out this morning from
your account recount can't you see I've
been set up
think you got a second shot it doesn't
want anything to do with you probably
remembering the sex right now little
shut up with this smug look off your
face
so you can't protect me I'm doing
everything I can within the law I want
my life back
Frenship no it's a good friendship and
then a good friendship you only tell
each other the good things did you take
a piss today four drops you same more or
less more